el cementerio de áfrica tiene varias
tumbas nuevas los residentes que en un
principio fueron enterrados en sus
patios por sus vecinos han sido
trasladados aquí de nats a togo y jubeto
fraternas
fueron asesinados el 12 de marzo el 14
los enterramos a un metro de profundidad
les ataron las manos a la espalda los
pusieron de rodillas y les dispararon en
la cabeza
los lugareños dicen que los rusos
esperaban ser recibidos como
libertadores y se volvieron asesinos
cuando vieron que no fue así al
principio su política era no tocar a los
civiles pero luego vieron como todos los
civiles estaban en contra de ellos
entonces empezaron a considerarnos a
todos como enemigos de la familia de
andy se considera afortunada salieron
después de una semana bajo los
bombardeos y regresaron para encontrar
su casa saqueada pero intacta
la metralla golpeó aquí suerte que la
casa no se quemó es una casa de madera
así que el riesgo de incendio era real
gracias a dios no sucedió
unas cuantas puertas más arriba ser y
está sacando equipo de construcción de
su casa sin terminar los soldados rusos
la ocuparon
es desagradable no quiero mudarme más ni
siquiera quiero terminar el trabajo de
ojos la pregunta que surge es por qué
algunos hombres sobrevivieron mientras
que otros fueron asesinados en su
mayoría buscaban veteranos de las
operaciones en el donbass del ejército
ucraniano
serhiy cuenta que él mismo es un
veterano del donbass y tuvo suerte de
que no lo encontrarán